il y a quelques instants à peine, New York a été
attaqué, des témoins ont affirmé avoir vu des
centaines d'OVNIS et ouvrir d'
où venons-nous, qui sommes-nous ces gars-là de
toute façon Nazis de la lune un mot de
moi à l'invasion de la lune commence
tu dois trébucher maintenant  ma question est de savoir
ce que vous prévoyez tous de faire à ce sujet
parce que nous avons juste un petit
quelque chose dans notre manche
tous les présidents qui déclenchent une guerre au cours de leur
premier mandat sont réélus un pilote Fagen
est la dimension f1 je compte dans la merde cela
garde  de mieux en mieux
nous sommes
- une nation
je devrais être une
le monde est malade nous sommes les médecins
casinos de Valhalla